You're not yet
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
Wasam
[Silence]
for.
So here in the virtues of knowledge
narrates a very well-known narration.
It's been narrated from a number of
companions
and it's been narrated
in a number of the books of hadith
in which the prophet sallall.aii
tells us about two types of people.
He says in this narration,
there is no valid
reasonable jealousy
that a one person should be jealous of
another or one person should be envious
of another
except two types of people, two
situations.
And what's meant here by jealousy, by
envy
is not
hassed in its true original form.
Because what is hasset?
There's an narration.
It's not an authentic narration.
It is often cited
that tells us that
Hassad
that
envy devours a person's sins and eats it
up.
, excuse me. that
envy
devours and consumes a person's good
deeds, a person's merits, hasset,
just as thoroughly as fire
consumes
grass or dried grass.
What does this mean? This jealousy is
one of the four pillars of kufur.
We have pillars for Islam, right? Four
pillars of Islam. five pillars of
Islam. How many pillars are there for
kufur? Four pillars. And one of them is
envy.
That envy
is not just that a person desires what
another has.
That's not envy in its truest form. Envy
in its truest form is that a person
desires what another has and desires it
so that he can be better than others.
That's a very important distinction.
And so some scholars say that the true
nature of jealousy
which is prohibited which is a pillar of
kufur etc is that you wish that you had
something someone else has and that they
didn't have it.
So that jealousy it is mixed with a
desire to be
singled out with good things.
That's the exact stark opposite of right
because we know that
the opposite is true for the believers.
None of you will truly believe until he
loves and desires for his brother what
he loves and desires for himself.
So when a person is jealous, envious
as Allah says
this is not just that they see something
nice and they wish they had it too.
is that only they had that nice thing
and that they are better and higher than
everyone else.
So,
a guy sees a nice car,
a woman sees a nice house or a fancy
handbag or whatever it is that people
desire,
they say, you know, I'd really to
have one of those myself. This is not
jealousy in its dispraised, denounced
sense. Jealousy is when they say, "I
wish that guy didn't have that car. I
wish I had that car and he didn't have
it and I was the one who got all the
eyeballs when I rolled into the parking
lot." Right? That is the jealousy that
is mentioned. I wish I don't wish
that so and so
had a that I had a good husband like
so and so has a good husband. No, I wish
I had the best husband and I was the
envy of all other women's husbands.
Right? Or I was the envy of all other
people's wives etc. This is the jealousy
which is a branch of kufur in its true
sense.
However, there's another type of envy
in which a person merely desires for
himself what another has.
I I want them to have it, but I wish I
had it too. Right?
This is not the way of the believer
except in two things.
meaning nothing that you see another
person having is worth your envy even in
this most innocent sense except one of
two things.
So he says
he says nothing is worthy of your envy
except two things.
He says two types of people are the only
type of people that are worthy of a
believer's envy. What are those two
types of people? He said, "A man, a
person, a man whom Allah has given
immense wealth to
he
concentrates that wealth
on all that is good for the sake of
Allah." I mean he takes that wealth and
he concentrates it on that which pleases
Allah giving it for the sake of Allah
for the path of Allah etc and and of
course those are many avenues
that person not just a person with money
but a person with money who knows how to
use it
in order to garner Allah's attention
and garner garner Allah's praise and
forgiveness and mercy and to garner
Allah's pleasure
that person
is worthy of to for people to be envious
of him and what is the second type he
says
notice the wording here very specific
wording he didn't just Say
[Silence]
had a
he says, "And Another
worthy of envy is someone whom Allah has
given alikmma to. Now he didn't say just
knowledge and he didn't just say the
Quran and he didn't just say the sunnah
and he didn't just say revelation. He
said alikmma
al hikma in the Quran
when it is used in reference to
knowledge it is not just knowledge but
it is the nuances
secrets wisdoms and true meanings of the
Quran and sunnah. That is what alikna
is.
Alhikna
[Silence]
And so wisdom here is knowledge of the
Quran, knowledge of the Sunnah,
knowledge of its application.
and knowledge of the nuances and wisdoms
of the Quran and Sunnah. So it is the it
is essentially what the the
results or the conclusions
of knowing the Quran and Sunnah. He
says, "And a man whom Allah has given a
hikma to."
And so he
implements it
and teaches it to others. He implements
it and he implements it in judging
between people and in judging situations
and he teaches it to others. So two
types of people. A man of wealth who
doesn't just give for the sake of Allah.
No, he concentrates it on all that Allah
loves. He uses that wealth if not if any
if for anything for the pleasure of
Allah. And the second is a man whom
Allah has given knowledge to and he uses
and implements that knowledge and
teaches it to others. These are the only
two types of people that are worthy of
your attention, that are worthy of a
believer's envy.
Anyone else?
Not worth the time of day. They do not
deserve a place in the believer's mind,
in the believer's heart, and in the
believer's consciousness
as if they are a non- entity. But these
two types, they are the only
praiseworthy of those things. And this
narration honestly has a lot of benefits
in it. if not only the benefits of
the
the nature of knowledge and the
nature of wealth
that those two things have a lot of
parallels,
but both of them have been given this by
Allah.
Yes, they had to earn it in whatever way
they earned it. But ultimately, it is
what? It is a gift from Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Nice to see you.